all right we've got cody joining us now
cody how are you
what's going on guys sorry for the
detour there a little bit we're trying
to do a little math and it gets a little
crazy sometimes do you know what 0.09 of
a billion is
i play uh sean perry's game which is no
public match we play that game too
and then we go do the public math and it
is a train wreck every single time so uh
how are you everything seems to be
pretty good in uh
the land of cash flow compared to uh
speculating on tech stocks in the public
market or uh trying to buy the next
great cryptocurrency
yeah i think it's been good so far kathy
wood uh i think is having a tougher time
but we're we're doing pretty good on the
cash flow side but again michael rubin
and her have billions and i don't yet so
i guess who's got the last laugh that
that is a a fair point but his is on
paper he's got to he's got to pull it
out into uh into cash then we'll uh
we'll believe it uh all right so i want
to talk to you about a whole bunch of
different stuff first i've seen you
posting all over instagram ice vending
machines and when i first saw this i was
like man i used to think that the two
scams in the world were selling water
and then selling air and those two
things would possibly not ever become a
real business and then the big brain
somewhere came up with selling frozen
water
in a bag is in these ice vending
machines so explain what's going on here
and how these businesses work
yeah it's wild well we're actually doing
a deal right now with one of the
companies it's called ice house of
america and of course you could guess
who owns them which is private equity
firms because they always know where the
zeros are um but essentially what this
is is i was driving around austin texas
and we have this one main street i'm
sure you guys have seen it too but like
gas station convenience store or
whatever and right next to it was this
little house and in the house there was
a line this day of people waiting to get
a bag of ice that slides out the chute
and they put it in their ice chest and
off they go and i was like wait a second
no employees
nobody around like no um you know hard
assets besides this tiny little thing
what i imagine was a couple hundred
dollar lease what is this business and
is it profitable and so i went down my
little rabbit hole and realized there's
this whole industry called ice venting
and there are thousands of these all
over the country and they're kind of
these little
passive-ish businesses similar to a car
wash or a laundromat where essentially
you set up the infrastructure and then
people pay you for common services and
what's wild is the margins on these
things i mean a bag of of
ice in austin texas is pre-inflation so
who knows now by the numbers are
different but let's call it you know um
75 cents typically
now the price is closer to a dollar
fifty dollars 75. um and uh and you get
your bag costs you anywhere from 15 to
25 cents and so you make the margin or
the difference between the two and i
love these little boring business nobody
thinks about super easy to run high
margin low people businesses so pretty
much all you have to do is you have to
hook up the
water and then it's freezing it inside
of the machine and making the ice and
really the only other material uh is
electricity and then the uh bags
themselves and like if you have those
three things then you're in business
with one of these machines that's
exactly right you need the land you need
the machine you need some bags that are
inside of it and you need a water hookup
and electricity hookup and then you want
to be like on a street corner that has
about 10 000 cars a day that's pretty
easy to check any realtor i'll be able
to tell you what the car count is
typically um so you need some foot
traffic or to be located by like a
school or lots of construction sites or
um a lake national parks um but those
that's kind of all you need for this
sort of business and then it's
relatively cheap to start anywhere from
what's called 25 to 150k for the machine
and then like i said you could lease the
land but the machines you get um
equipment loans on so those start at a
couple hundred bucks a month um for you
to kind of get rolling and the break
even looks like you start breaking even
well you start making money month one if
you do your due diligence right
obviously and pick the right location
and then it looks like the break even on
these things is anywhere from three to
six years which is really low for real
estate so when you think about this uh
atms the business that we've spent a lot
of time looking at we actually have a
bitcoin atm sitting in here right now uh
when we think about those they're paying
the gas station or or location to put it
in their store and that's why the store
allows them to put it there uh and then
they just are taking their fee are these
ice vending machines are they paying to
place their uh uh unit or are they uh
just paying some sort of like uh lease
or like how does this work exactly to
the way that they get it uh in the
location
usually a lease so very cheap because
you only need one segment of the parking
lot let's call it like a parking space
and a half so that people can kind of
turn around
um so they're leasing and the leases are
pretty cheap like i said i mean it
depends on the city so wide variability
but let's call it 200 bucks to 500 bucks
a month um you could have a lease on
something like that i probably go on the
lower end there but you're exactly right
now the reason i like ice mending i've
done a decent amount of looking at atm
machines you guys are the cryptokings so
i'm not gonna mess with you there but um
the atm machine model i don't love
because the margins are actually so tiny
and you know cash is increasingly not as
utilized so um bitcoin i think is is
interesting um but any of the people
that have reached out to us we own some
laundromats they've reached out to put
bitcoin atms in the laundromats um and
they pay us a flat fee because my
understanding is uh you can't take a cut
on bitcoin transactions without some
sort of licensing so yeah that's the
difference between the two got it that
makes sense um there's other vending
machines i know that you're very
interested in ice is obviously probably
the most basic uh just freezing water uh
but carvana is like on the other end of
uh this spectrum where they literally
have a car vending machine and i
remember there was some pretty big
profiles and articles written on the
carvana founders it was this really hot
company kind of pre-tech
route but why is that business so
interesting to you
yeah have you ever seen one of their
vending machines they're pretty cool
they're wild so if for people who
haven't seen it you should google it
right now but basically like let's say
like five or six stories glass kind of
looks like an elevator but for cars and
inside of it is um you know you can
select on a little app or on your phone
or website the car that you want and
literally click purchase and then the
car rolls out of the vending machine my
brother actually bought and sold one
through carvana because they do used and
new the wild part about this company is
i went to high school with the uh
founder of it his name's ernie garcia
and back in the day what i like about
this business it's kind of techy today
but there's two reasons i like it one is
it started from this other company
called ugly dunk ugly duckling uh cars
and that got bought and turned into this
company called drive time by his dad but
basically he just bought up used car
lots
made a ton of money was one of the
richest dudes in arizona where i'm from
uh there we go that's a picture of it um
and uh and through this boring business
his son then did what i think is going
to happen across the u.s which is taking
these old boring businesses and
transitioning them into 21st century
technologically forward businesses in
ways that we can't imagine and that i
think is carvano so carvana now is like
16 or 18 billion dollar market cap you
guys can check they're publicly listed
um you know ernie's a billionaire a few
times over so is his dad and they all
did it through taking these boring
businesses
doing another boring business which we
know all about which is vending machines
compiling the two with technology and
making it easier for the end user and
think about it like there is nothing
more miserable than going and buying a
car and having to go to the sales person
and there's all the tactics and you sign
the thing and they give you a hot dog
and so you have reciprocity whole
thing's a nightmare and basically ernie
just said ah what if we put this thing
like in a little tower and we just vent
them out and millennials don't like to
talk to people uh ever if humanly
possible so we're going to cut out the
middleman and with that we're going to
actually be able to take a better margin
and profit so they've totally crushed it
with the boring biz integration do you
think that more and more vending machine
type businesses will pop up where this
is vending machine of cars there's
vending machine of ice like will we see
this over and over again and what
immediately think of it is there was a
startup i don't know if it ended up
being successful or shut down or if
they're still going but they were
basically creating the equivalent of a
vending machine mixed with like a bodega
and they're putting it in uh apartment
complex you know lobbies where they were
saying hey
rather than just come and get you know
your pack of peanuts or uh a gatorade
they had kind of a much larger variety
it was higher quality um goods that were
inside of this but it basically was a
vending machine that you paid there was
no employee et cetera it's like is this
gonna happen across the entire economy
yeah i mean i think you're already
seeing it think about have you you know
in miami maybe not as much but
definitely in new york and even in
austin you go to an apartment building
right and you used to have like boxes
piled behind the the front reception
desk right for amazon whatever what do
you have today you have a literal box
vending machine right and so you like
input this code and in the code it pops
open some door that's special size for
the type of box that you can have so you
don't have to talk to a human um and so
i think this is going to happen all over
the place and vending won't be the only
thing i'm not like thinking there's
going to be a vending revolution but
anywhere you can decrease the amount
human engage because what happened
through kovid
we're going to remember that that's our
ptsd of our generation um so anything
where you can decrease the interaction
between humans where you can automate
processes and then given the fact that
you know people don't want to work as
much anymore and we're having this great
resignation and the great retirement
people can't get this level of labor and
so what's gonna happen anywhere where
something can be automated it's going to
be automated in the future i think uh
except at the highest levels for service
and luxury and so yeah that's that's my
bet at least
yeah it does feel like this is just all
a form of automation it sounds kind of
dumb in elementary when we call it a
vending machine right but like to some
degree that's what we're watching happen
here um when you start to think about uh
existing businesses how much of this is
going to be like the carvana example
where uh somebody understands enough of
the industry but they're younger and so
they say hey let's go and uh and kind of
revolutionize this uh industry versus
it's actually the people who own the
business today who are constantly just
trying to save cost and they're going to
have the foresight to uh to kind of do
some of this
i think it'll be a mix you know i have a
friend brandon wallace who started a fun
called fifth wall and it's all built on
the built world so his idea was real
estate is the most sort of backwards
old-school industry out there there's
like paper ledgers there's nothing
online you know you blockchain guys hate
that and so um most you know real estate
companies like a lot of them still have
keys and actual lock boxes right it's
really archaic and so he built this fund
that's now multi-billion dollars that
all it does is look for where can we
apply technology to the built world aka
real estate and they actually have a
storage company that two guys who were
in storage so they understood the
industry said wait a second why do we
have these like storage boxes you know
like you go to a storage center and you
have this whole huge box and like most
of the time those things aren't filled
all the way right it's not like uh
capacity utilization in the smart way so
they were like why can't we instead
take your stuff catalog it actually
online so we know everything that's in
your storage unit you don't have to dig
through all of it and then when you want
something you actually ping us on demand
for that item it's almost like you know
if you could imagine like a dry cleaning
thing where like you know it's like
spinning and then like you grab the
shirt out of it or whatever um that's
their idea for the storage company so i
think it'll be a mix i think my bet is
you know we invest in all of these
boring businesses right like mom and pop
shops and i'm seeing those uh companies
be bought or taken over by the younger
generation who's saying like why are we
doing it this way this is crazy and so
applying something to their pain to
create a solution that becomes a new
company aka carvana or the storage
company and then of course i think
you're going to have people come in like
i think we both know perry hurst from
pipe um who's like why are we doing you
know credit this way why can't boring
businesses or normal businesses get
better credit based on their future uh
uh invoices and payments and so he
created pipe fastest i think company to
a billion dollars in valuation so he was
an outsider right
yeah it's uh it's fascinating to kind of
think through uh as we go through this
market downturn i know that uh you've
always been very focused on cash flow
which uh tends to be a pretty uh
effective way to weather these how are
you seeing people take liabilities and
turn them into assets and any examples
there
yeah couple well one i think this is
huge so a lot of people like to you know
talk badly about this they're like these
businesses are too simplistic we could
be much smarter than this but in my mind
and you know we've already seen it
what's happening with inflation and then
if you end up getting you know losing
your job or we have this recessionary
pullback or your assets aren't worth
what they used to be worth um i think
people have to start thinking a lot more
intelligently about the things they
already own and you're starting to see
it so a couple things that you know i'm
pushing uh for even my family to do is
things like renting out cars on turo you
know we have um like you know a couple
places and in every place that we're not
in we rent them out onturo and we rent
them out on airbnb and then we own part
of the property management company and
we own part of the
um
vehicle management company so like
owning the companies that can actually
turn the things that cost you money
every month into assets is something
that people talk about but very few
people do and now there are all of these
companies that do this i mean there's a
company here in texas that does it for
your pool so you can actually just like
rent out your pool to people what
yeah yeah how much that would cost for
me to rent out a pool i i think it
varies but how nice of a pool you want
pompano
if you're at home somebody just like
comes over and it's like partying at
your pool you're inside your house yeah
it's called swimply
swim please like swim simply rent
beautiful private pools by the hour now
i have no idea if this thing's a joke or
not i've never actually used this
company yeah but um but they've been
around it looks like for three years uh
and so i think you're gonna have this
stuff pop up everywhere because we've
been seeing people buy things at record
levels during covid and they're gonna
have to figure out how to deal with that
i mean another great example is like
yeah out of here with these pills
you see this 45 bucks you can get like a
nice nice pool in miami 100 bucks an
hour
a hundred percent yeah you got to go to
someone's house yeah i mean of course
yeah
you said can i use your bathroom real
quick but yeah that's awesome i wonder
do you get to actually go into that like
what if you got to go to the bathroom
what can you use the grill like i wonder
it's probably all within there there's
actually like a lot of pools on here i
wouldn't have expected as much inventory
but there's like a ton of them you know
what else people are probably gonna
start doing is uh i bet you you could
rent out if you got a really dope
basketball uh court either uh if you got
like a big house that's on your property
or it's in your driveway and uh if the
public parks are always uh backed up
then you could basically just rent out
the uh basketball goal and say hey you
and like all your friends can come play
basketball on my driveway i assume that
they have 50 bucks it's built out for
everything right like obviously houses
were first with airbnb turo is cars they
have boat setter for for boats here in
miami now you can do pools like
essentially anything that anyone else
wants to use or rent that they don't
have you could build out a service yeah
cody talk to us about the turo business
how how how does that work
well that one's interesting so um
basically how it works is uh you have a
car whatever your your normal vehicle is
and you list it just like you would on
airbnb on an app okay and the app
essentially allows somebody to rent your
car without you have been the middleman
there's insurance through turo all the
payments are done through turo um you
have reviews just like you do on airbnb
and you can rent out a few of them and
so um we actually have i don't want to
manage the individual cars but what
we've done is just reached out to other
people when we've rented in locations
and said and if it was a good service
basically just said hey you want to rent
out a couple of our cars and just take
care of it when we're not there and then
the cool part is when we come into town
we're like drop the car off the airport
like we'll see you and meet you there
and then we're gonna you know drop it
off at the airport when we get there
somebody like will pop in our car and
take it away and then you know the part
that i think is interesting that people
haven't thought about yet is just like
the luxury level level of these services
like i would pay an extra a couple
hundred bucks for somebody to do that
drop off and pick up for me at the
airport with my rental car like every
single time as opposed to having to go
to hertz or do the thing or get like a
black car everywhere um so i think that
lux level is gonna actually happen a lot
more as well and i haven't seen that
happen yet do they have any services
that will rent private drivers
uh so like not uber where i order a car
and then they take me everywhere in
their car
but i wonder if there's people who say
you know i got a ball in car i'm keeping
my car but i just want somebody to come
drive me around in it
oh yeah there is a service that does i
got to imagine somebody
somebody yeah of course it's in miami
like somebody somewhere definitely has
got to have that one up and running
right but like your point is uh there is
this whole kind of uh technology slash
like economic transition that's
occurring where you can pay for things
by the hour you can use the vending
machine type model like you just see the
economy slowly shifting uh to something
that's more technology enabled more
marketplace enabled than uh than maybe
we previously saw you know 20 30 years
ago
yeah i i think you're exactly right and
then people always kind of talk about
like well i don't have enough money to
do that it must be nice cody you got a
few cars or whatever and my response is
like there's always like three sides to
the marketplace you know you can have of
course you can have the people with all
the assets who have the things that they
can rent out but you could also be the
guy who does the logistics for the
people who have the stuff that they want
to rent out or you could be the guy who
says to the people with money hey uh i
want to you know buy a bunch of cars and
rent them out ontario why don't you back
my venture and we'll be partners in them
so like i don't think having money is or
not having money as an excuse you could
be into any side of the three-sided
marketplace and do the same exact thing
um in fact like you guys know this i'm
sure it's damn hard to find people who
want to operate businesses right now and
so you know if a young gun came to me
with a business plan flushed out those
are my favorite type of people to get
into business with do you want to know
the business that i absolutely would uh
would get in with somebody if we found
the right person to do it is airbnb
party houses
so the whole idea
of airbnb is people rent out their homes
but what does everybody want they want
the like family coming on vacation
that's going to take good care of it
like don't have any parties it's usually
written in the airbnb uh you know
description like everyone wants the uh
really boring use of their property
but what is everyone who's renting
trying to do right i know a ton of
people who are like damn we're gonna
throw
uh a party it doesn't have to be like
you know
kegs and and uh kind of like a frat
style party but it could just be a
wedding reception it could be some sort
of a baby shower or you know whatever
but they want to actually have the party
at a nice house
and so if you could find a bunch of them
who said yeah sure like as long as you
guys come here and clean up afterwards
and there's insurance and you know kind
of all the downside risk is taken care
of like
actually i want people to throw parties
here i've got a great backyard for
barbecues or or whatever to me that
feels like a huge opportunity that you
know goes directly against what most
people on an airbnb want to do with
their home
yeah that's such a good point actually
um i wonder if that exists yeah we one
of our airbnbs
we um
it was in austin texas so this is like
on brand but basically um our airbnb
manager was telling us that uh he saw
like 20 people come in to the airbnb but
they were all bringing yoga mats but it
was like nine o'clock at night so it was
like what are these people doing in the
house because we have an outdoor camera
there um and it's a it's a nice house
and uh and basically and then they moved
all the furniture around and we have a
sound audible um you know measure in
each of the airbnbs we have to make sure
somebody doesn't throw a giant party but
essentially what i think they were doing
is they were totally having like a
psychedelic journey or whatever in our
house they like left us this ridiculous
crystal at the end of it it was like so
austin but um i'm sure there were a lot
of flapper and hats you know and
whatever feathers but um but the moral
of the story what we found out later
from the guy is like yeah we charge like
you know five thousand dollars a person
to to throw these so if i was only
charging 1500 bucks a night i you know
had your model i'd be saying yeah i want
5k but have a have a party do whatever
you want set up the shaman crystal don't
care um so i like that idea oh i think
people would pay
bonkers numbers in miami one of the big
things that actually happened
uh is i know a couple of folks who they
would come for you know whether it's
miami tech week or uh the bitcoin
conference or whatever and they're like
man it was really hard to actually find
uh an airbnb uh because i i'm bringing
my whole team and i was like what do you
mean and what they were explaining to me
was they were bringing you know seven
eight ten people from their company that
lived all around uh kind of the country
or the world
and so they wanted to rent a full house
well to see or you know to kind of have
seven eight ten people live in a house
in miami you gotta get a pretty nice
house well it turns out that the people
who have those really nice homes on
airbnb
they know that people are looking for
these like corporate retreat style uh
destinations and so a house that is you
know three four five million dollars
they were renting them out for anywhere
between 50 to 75 000 a month
because the corporates were paying
right so if you're gonna you know how
much would you pay if you're gonna bring
10 people
to a city
and not only are they going to live
there but that's where you're going to
do work or whatever for like a uh a two
week off site
would you pay i don't know 35 000 as a
company like
maybe that doesn't sound as crazy
because if you start to do like 10 hotel
rooms every night for two weeks like it
gets up there and so
i was fascinated with this idea of
basically luxury homes but they're not
renting them to families or to
individuals they were renting them for
this more like kind of corporate
off-site uh for companies that are
distributed in terms of their employee
base i love that i gotta go fire my
property manager because we're not
getting thirty five thousand dollars for
a weekend everybody's fired um but uh i
love that idea i also think you know i'm
really into i think we're gonna talk
about this too today but this idea of um
how can we get people access to these
sorts of investments so like
you know this airbnb for instance we own
a few it's kind of a pain like the
reason i own the property management
company too is you pay the guy 20 to 25
for them to manage your your properties
and that's a lot of the cut after the
you know whatever 10 airbnb takes and so
um i wanted to own both but then it's
you know it's also expensive you got to
put the money down for the place it
probably costs you three to 5k to get it
set up you know right for airbnb with
cameras and everything you need and um
and so i was i've been sniffing or
sniffing around a lot and this is more
your lane these days too about how can
we get investment access to these types
of deals at cheaper levels and so i'm
messing around there's this one company
called here dot co i'm early on in due
diligence with them but i like the model
and they basically let you fractionalize
airbnb investments um so that you know
somebody can get in with a hundred or a
thousand bucks and they've done it in a
way where you don't have to be
accredited and so i i love the idea i
mean when i see the returns we have
rental properties right normal ones
somebody runs for a year whatever versus
airbnb i mean the numbers are
astronomically different we keep both
because i think it's important for a
market but airbnb is so much more
profitable if done right
what are some other ideas that you're
like super interested in right now that
are just weird like i know that you guys
are are setting up a fund and so you
guys have uh maybe can't share all of
the the weird weird ones but like what
are the things that uh people wouldn't
think are good investment opportunities
but you guys are like man we love this
idea yeah well that's the fun part these
days is i think there's a lot more so
there are i have sort of a thesis the
thesis is this that we talked about it
early on but that boring businesses are
going to transition to more technology
and innovation within these businesses
that nobody cares about aka landscaping
plumbing uh you know air conditioning
companies etc there's been this whole
revolution where elderly you know more
elderly citizens baby boomers whatever
are retiring and they're shutting down
these businesses or transferring them to
the next generation so there's a way of
a bunch of people like me buying them
that's cool but the problem with just
buying boring businesses is you don't
get non-linear returns right like my my
plumbing company is not gonna be worth a
hundred thousand dollars this year and
then a hundred million in two years
unless we do some crazy things but you
can have those kind of jumps with
technology so the part that i think's
interesting is silicon valley's right
now a lot focused on the metaverse and a
lot of things that i don't fully
understand that are super sexy that i
think are interesting but they're not as
much focused on these you know boring
businesses that can have incremental
return with technology so that's the
stuff i'm interested in like for example
i don't like to own uh franchises
typically outright because i don't like
rules that's why i'm an employee i'm
probably not an entrepreneur and
probably unemployable but there's this
company called friendshares and um
this company actually fractionalizes
franchise investments in a fund platform
similar like fundrise or wealthfront and
so that's i think super interesting um
and then another one that i want to do
more of similar to to pipe is factoring
so we're looking at a few companies this
couldn't be more boring like people are
probably falling asleep listening to me
but basically it's there's all this
money trapped in small businesses right
so like if you talk to anybody that runs
an e-commerce business their life is
pretty miserable they could be doing 50
million
but they have like zero dollars in their
bank account because they have to
forward buy all the inventory and now
with supply chain issues you know they
might not be getting the inventory to
then sell it to then get paid like net
30 or net 60 on some of that if they if
they sell to retail and so um there's
all this trapped money and i think
there's going to be some really
interesting companies that open up that
trapped money that allow for these
companies to be a lot more profitable um
because they don't have a you know 30 to
120 day window where they're floating
the revenue of the company um and that's
that's called factoring so those are a
couple ones that i think that are
interesting today
got it and so when you start to think
about this would you rather own what i
would consider like a traditional small
business with cash flow like um i don't
know a plumbing company or you know
those types of businesses versus like an
ice vending machine how do you balance
uh not just like an economic
underwriting of like which one makes
more money but how do you think about
the risks and upside of those two
different types of businesses
i think buying small businesses is like
buying real estate you got to scale up
and so it's just like a stair step so
use the reason i talk about things like
laundromats or ice vending companies is
because they're much cheaper to start
with less risk typically so you know you
can buy an ice vending machine for
thirty thousand dollars on
uh you know a line of credit you have an
asset that you could actually sell to
somebody else and you don't have that
much in reoccurring costs and so that's
a pretty cheap way to get uh cash flow
day one theoretically um and so i talk
about those but that's kind of like real
estate like you know you could buy your
little apartment and then the next one
you buy a townhouse and then after the
townhouse you buy the multi-family then
you buy you know the industrial land or
whatever um and i think the same way
buying businesses so for me today i need
to buy bigger businesses for them to be
worthwhile um because the bigger
business you have the more
fat you have in it that can absorb some
of the pain of running a small business
like people quitting and having to deal
with labor costs etc so when you're just
starting out you want a lean business
probably that you can learn from that's
not too much risk something like
potentially a laundromat or a car wash
or a nice vending machine business or a
vending machine business because they
start small and then you realize oh my
gosh doing a small deal is almost as
much work as doing a larger deal and
it's probably more work following
because you don't have the employees in
the business the fad in the business
that allows you to step out as the
person who is the owner of the operator
so when you say plumbing inverse ice
vending i think more like size and scale
so if i have an ice vending business
that's like 150 locations and i have a
bunch of guys that run it and they send
me checks every month great but if i
have a plumbing company that you know
only does 300 000 in revenue and 50 000
in profit and so i'm you know having to
fix toilets like probably not so great
so i think it's really a size thing as
opposed to industry sector yeah it's
fascinating to think about that uh talk
to us about this fund i don't know what
you're allowed to say what you're not
allowed to say but uh you're starting a
fund what to help people invest in these
opportunities but you'll be the one
selecting or how does it work yeah
exactly well the cool part is so i
haven't raised money for two years um
because i've just seen valuations look
crazy and so i didn't want to raise
money and deploy capital in that type of
environment now what i'm starting to see
is that on the early side for
investments you're starting to see
evaluations come down i mean everybody's
been talking about this companies are
starting to have down rounds right about
now is when i think makes sense to raise
a little capital so what we're gonna do
typically i've only raised from
institutions um because and you know
this you had a fund for a long time it's
it's a pain to manage other people's
money if you don't have to um it's
actually more fun and easier just to
manage your own but we have this
ecosystem that contrarian thinking which
i think will be fun to have people have
access to you have to be accredited
we're going to do it through angel list
it's going to be very small like 5-10
million bucks max and the idea is
you know invest on these four trends
one great resignation two great
retirement three the fact that uh
increasingly these boring businesses are
not selling at all there's so much
supply and not a lot of demand and then
four ecosystems so you have this too
i've never seen something more powerful
than a media company paired with capital
um the fact that we can de-risk
investments like franchise for instance
you know before we were looking at them
we sent them out to our email list and
we're like do people want to invest in
this and then like 20 000 people signed
up for the email list they got a couple
million dollars in investors that wanted
to come into their next fund so i was
able to actually de-risk our investment
slightly through our audience and so
that's the idea is maybe there's this
flywheel these days andreessen horowitz
saw it
between
not just having capital but capital
and audience and then capital and then
audience and then capital and audience
and i think that'll be one of our
differentiators in the boring business
space yeah it's fascinating uh my last
question for you is uh as part of going
bigger getting bigger companies
valuations coming down i know that
you've been communicating with the
companies you already do own a portion
of about just like hey prepare like
tighten the belt i think is the way that
you describe it what what is your
thought process in terms of why they
should be prepared for a potential
more pain in the future
yeah do you ever remember the sequoia
sequoia or andreessen horowitz set the
tombstone powerpoint out you remember
that yes yeah so um so they sent that
out in like 99 right before the tech
bubble burst and like i'm not that smart
but i was in cannabis before this that
was one of our other funds and i sent
that email out to all of our cannabis
companies and let's see right before the
cannabis downturn which would have been
like 2017 2018 and i was like you guys
are crazy your valuations are not right
you're doing market share land grabs you
aren't profitable this is going to go
sideways start sucking away cash right
now raise capital right now and start
tightening your belts because it's going
to be painful and again it doesn't take
a rocket scientist to see this lonely i
said this it's public you can see it i
said it at the biggest conference in
cannabis lo and behold the cannabis
market tanks it's never really recovered
from that point even though the
companies that have stayed solid are now
moving towards profitability and i think
the same thing is going to happen for us
in the um early stage market right now
um and it's already happening i mean
we've seen a ton of these companies i
mean how many shows on netflix are about
these companies uh imploding lately i
think we're in that same segment so i've
basically said hey listen you know
all-time high inflation um you know
decreasing gdp we've got the second
largest port in china uh looks like it's
going through shutdowns i'm getting sent
crazy videos from my friends in china i
gotta send you this one pomp it's like
that she lowers her dog in a harness
with a helmet on outside of her building
in shanghai uh it's like she's three
fours up on a rope so the dog can pee
and then then they rope the dog back up
because they're not allowed out of their
house um so like we're gonna have these
ripples that are wild and uh if
companies aren't ready for it you don't
have at least 18 months of runway i
think you're going to think you wish you
wish you had yeah i i tend to think uh
you want to be prepared in case it goes
really bad and if it doesn't go really
bad then you can accelerate deploy the
money grow
and everything's fine and you'll laugh
about oh man we were we were over
prepared but it's kind of like a natural
disaster
nobody when the really bad natural
disasters hit is mad that they prepared
100 percent of people
uh that over prepare always are like man
that was a waste of time right but then
the question is not like hey should we
have done it or not it's like what do
you do the next time and so that feels a
little bit like businesses right of like
look who knows how bad it could get but
being prepared is gonna end up being a
an incredibly important detail here joe
john what questions do you guys have hey
cody my my question would just be around
how people get started and your thoughts
around kind of uh borrowing money or
taking on debt to do this i assume that
is not the the recommendation in most
cases uh but in a lot of cases also
people don't have the capital that maybe
requires to start some of these
businesses just talk me through your
thoughts on how people can start with a
little bit of cash if that's all they
have
yeah well a couple things one um you can
do an sba loan with a personal guarantee
i think that's really scary to do if you
don't have any money and it's your first
time doing a business so my personal
like if i was in that case i wouldn't
want to do that i wouldn't want to put
everything i own on the line for a
business that i've never bought before
and run it that's scary kudos to the
people that do that now if you've run a
bunch of businesses that's not so scary
you're like oh great this is like
basically free money here's how it works
no problem so when you're first starting
what i like to think about is there's
like three legs to the stool you either
have money you have time or you have
expertise
most people only think about one leg i
don't have money i can't buy a business
they forget about the other two if you
have expertise you can use your
expertise to get equity in a business
from telling other people how to run it
and you would just negotiate that in
your
package okay if you're a plumber get
partnered with somebody who has money or
who has time and you're the expertise
and they're the time and the money and
the same thing with time if you don't
have expertise or money go to somebody
like you know i don't know let's say joe
is really into this idea on turo go to
joe and say joe i don't have any capital
to buy a bunch of these cars but here's
my business plan i put together this
entire thing why don't you go in with me
from an equity standpoint and we'll do
this business together then there's also
a couple examples and um i think one's
called i was just looking it up over
here um this one's called like this 23
year old bought a 250k business for 1k
um
and basically it's about a young guy who
um bought a cleaning business he started
a cleaning business while he was in
college it's at contrarian thinking if
you guys want to check it out started a
cleaning business in college um
then bought one of his competitors
business who was retiring through what's
called a rep share so he was like i'll
give you a thousand dollars down and
then i'll give you 25 of the profits for
the next three to five years i can't
remember the deal terms there in the
article um but that happens all the time
and so what i get upset about is people
say no way can you do this you can't
start a business with any money you
can't buy a business with just a
thousand dollars and that's just
categorically not true is it easy do
they just come across your desk do
people just wave money in your face no
no [ __ ] way but are they an option
yes they are you just have to learn
about deals and terms
yeah john what do you got that's that's
great i've uh looked at a bunch of them
and a lot of seller financing is a big
option that people try to do but i'm
curious how do you advertise for all
these businesses i'm sure it's different
from vending machines to laundry mats
but like how do you think about
advertising
yeah totally depends on the business i
mean most of these businesses that if
you have one thing that's crucial to
small business it's reviews it's you
know yelp reviews online and if you
could optimize for reviews then in
service businesses that's the holy grail
the cool part is there's a lot of
technology now that lets you be a lot
smarter about reviews most small
businesses do not optimize for reviews
think about it how many times is your
cleaning lady your handyman your roofer
sent you like a follow-up text message
like with a nice little note or maybe a
video explaining to you how much a
review means to them how many of them
have an actual process for follow-up in
case you don't do a review for them that
is the best form of advertising for
small businesses like this is reviews
and there's um there's actually a cool
software i have to think about if i can
grab it really quick that allows you
nice job so it's called nice job and you
integrate it with your crm your customer
relationship management system and
basically it is a way for you to do a
follow-up to get reviews
that a lot of small businesses use it's
really good you could also use jabber
but nice jobs more particular for this
one gotcha
cody the last thing i want to ask you is
if you today it's monday by sunday night
i challenged you to come up with uh some
sort of activity or business where you
could make a thousand dollars per week
what would you do
without any of our unfair advantages
correct you just starting from scratch
you want to make a thousand dollars per
week what do you do
gosh i think probably the easiest thing
to do uh because it's it's not that hard
is like go to anybody who's a media
persona i'm sure like like you or me
and start creating content based on
their content for them i think you could
not just make a thousand dollars a week
you could make thousands like i have
people who ping me sometimes
sporadically like memes let's say for
twitter or they'll ping me like a little
video of just my stuff chopped up like
even if i'm not a good talent i would
just go and watch a bunch of your stuff
and then i would get on fiverr and get a
designer a video editor based uh
somewhere offshore and i would send you
like three to five videos like hey do
you like these if so awesome use them um
you know and if you think they're
interesting enough i'd love to to create
more content for you we everyone i know
is so hungry for content um and we all
make a lot of money on the internet and
otherwise i think it's a no-brainer to
become an outsourced content creator you
could create an agency in like five
minutes i mean um it's wild yeah that's
a pretty good answer i think one time
before we thought of um
uh what did we say uh you could go if
you want to make a thousand dollars one
time for the weekend uh you probably
you'd have to hustle but you could go
make a couple hundred bucks as a golf
caddy etc the problem is that a lot of
those uh they're not very scalable and
also uh they're very difficult because
they require some sort of physical uh
labor etc uh and then in some way like
the payment is kind of a tip right so
like you know maybe you get a good tip
or maybe you don't with this it's pretty
clear uh you're running an actual
business you can scale and also you can
set price which uh ends up being a much
better business to be in than like hey
i'm gonna go make some extra cash as a
uh
as a caddy
yeah i agree maybe the other thing if
you want to go more manual than tech
would be like um
like i might just like go buy a power
sprayer or something from home depot
actually could probably just rent one
and run around like a nice neighborhood
uh somewhere in your city and ask if you
can power wash people's driveways like
well this looks kind of dirty do you
need some power washing on this uh you
can't really screw up a driveway so i
don't think you could you know i
wouldn't power wash a house to start
with but that would probably be a really
quick way if i was a young kid to run
around the neighborhood and do something
like this services are really hard to
get right now for almost everybody i
mean we got a quote from a pool guy
yesterday for 400 a month to clean our
pool um so anything where you can make
somebody's house nicer and easier and
serve them like this i think you could
probably make some money really quick
how big is your pool you gotta pull the
size of the ocean for 100 to just come
and clean it it's the littlest pool this
is like this is not a mansion it's just
austin has such an influx of people
that we can't get somebody who can put
us in the rotation um and they're like
well maybe we could do it if we paid 400
i was like i'm about to learn about pool
cleaning that's not happening cody how
do you think about like if you went and
got a power wash for example how do you
think about pricing in that market
because i'm sure there's other people
that do power washing so like do you
just undercut them on price and try to
get as many customers as possible or
let me ask you a question what does it
cost to power wash your driveway
100 bucks 300 somewhere in that range
yeah you have no idea right so i have no
idea so i would basically just go around
the neighborhood and i'd start at one
price and then i'd keep going up to the
number of people that said yes and then
i'd stop once they start saying that's
ridiculous um i think like you know i
would probably say yeah it's oh i've got
a great offer for you usually this costs
300 i do it today for 99 because i
actually live in the neighborhood this
is my first business would you like you
know do you think you would give me a
chance at doing some power washing today
looks like you know there's pollen it's
springtime this is really good time you
don't want that stuff to set on your
driveway because that could totally
stain it i mean i would like come up
with some spiel like that um and sort of
rock and roll and then i'd probably be
extra lazy and i'd post it somewhere
like what's that terrible uh site like
next door where or open door next door
right everybody's complaining about
their neighbors all the time yeah i'd
post it on there um and i'm sure you'd
get people without even having to go
outside your door gotcha
where can we send people to uh one
follow you on the internet but also too
uh subscribe to the newsletter and find
out more about the fund
awesome um cody sanchez on twitter uh
c-o-d-i-e underscore sanchez on twitter
and then contrarian thinking dot co
is our newsletter and that'll be where
all the fun information is once that
goes live
look at that that's us i i i love the uh
the twitter banner image with uh
censored
yeah
i thought that was
pretty sassy
last thing actually i'm going to uh i
lied i have one more question
yes yes or no elon ends up owning
twitter when it's all said and done
yeah i'm with david sacks if he
does not have the right to buy the
company at the type of valuations he's
putting out there's something corrupt
happening in the free markets i think it
is categorically wrong what the twitter
board is doing although not surprising
yeah
i uh
uh i think that the
like the variable that no one's
accounting for
is if all of a sudden elon
toma uh bravo
peter t like there's a whole bunch of
different people who could come together
here
and be like name the price
oh yeah give them a bear hug that's what
it's called an offer too good that you
can't refuse um you know and if if i
think people this is interesting because
here's m a happening live
but i think people should if you want to
learn about this i mean you could read
like barbarians at the gate it was an
old school one you could read about carl
icahn i think it's called king khan or
something like that has a good book
about him activist takeover we were
involved in one relatively big hostile
takeover and they're they're gnarly and
i've been involved in a few tender
offers um but the problem is you know
it's terrible for twitter shareholders
it is an expensive proposal to go
through a tender offer it's distracting
for the company overall these guys
definitely don't need it um so yeah i
think you're right though uh he wants a
dog on a bone unless there's like some
other reason that he's doing this that i
don't understand which could be true too
i um
uh last week put together my uh what i
thought would be the uh perspective uh
uh twitter executive team and i said
elon should be the chairman peter chill
the ceo jordan peters who could be
president we could have uh keith roboy
as ceo donald trump as cfo dana white is
the chief marketing officer
snowden in charge of security joe rogan
is the head of hr and tim dillon would
take over investor relations and i think
that the company would be worth 20
gazillion dollars
my god that's the best line i had a mess
of that company i've seen tim uh
yeah i'm seeing dylan tonight he's uh
live in austin
he's a national treasurer yeah i think
you nailed it your takes on twitter are
second to none i can't believe i giggle
so much about bitcoin so silly yeah it's
uh i mean look anytime that you can put
together a whole list of uh white men
and then you call it the anti-woke team
you can imagine the people who get very
upset about uh yeah obvious joke um
i think next business needs to be ways
we can make sure we scrub all of our
addresses off of the internet everybody
always yells at me for not telling who
my businesses are online they're like
you don't own any i'm like have you met
you guys you think i should tell you
what businesses i own
the uh that what is it the um the uh
adversarial yelp like uh thing to small
businesses that still blows my mind it's
like now yelp will actually lock reviews
if there's an influx of a bunch of
negative reviews uh in a short period of
time because they feel like uh
yeah the mob is trying to destroy like a
small business whether it's warranted
not what whatever uh they've put uh
things in place to try to prevent some
of that but still i think it's smart it
happened to nick huber a sweaty startup
a mutual friend of mine he just got just
like his business online the reviews
were just crazy some death threats and
stuff so yeah i'm not trying to put my
small businesses through that because
you know it's one thing if it's my fine
go online and yell about contrary i'm
thinking that one's public but you know
don't mess with with my guy who's like a
first-gen immigrant to the us that runs
our landscaping business because you
don't like something i say and i happen
to give him money that's ridiculous yeah
i completely agree all right it's always
a pleasure to have you on uh we
appreciate it very much uh
we uh we i'm i'm waiting for somebody to
pitch me like a really good one and then
i'll make you a promise i'll i'll call
you and we'll uh we'll do it together
but uh if anyone in miami has a uh uh 45
million dollar mansion that they want to
run out for parties uh call us
yeah psychedelic or otherwise
miami and austin i'm into it you guys
thank you so much this is a blast love
everything you guys do all right bye
cody bye everybody